just three weeks old
baby beverly a cherished first daughter
but unbeknown to her parents
in this video she's already very sick
her little body is fighting covert 19.
foreign
[Music]
beverly's parents visited 10 hospitals
around jakarta before they found one
with space to take her
doctors successfully resuscitated her
three times
but when her heart stopped for the
fourth time
they couldn't save her
beverly was less than a month old when
she died
foreign
indonesian doctors have seen a surge in
covid19 cases and deaths in children
since july
10 year old kaka is one of more than
half a million under 18s to test
positives since the start of the
pandemic here
her mother brought her in with breathing
problems
almost all the family has the virus
along the corridor 18 day old seraphine
is responding well to treatment
she was four days old when
19 has killed a record number of
indonesian children in august more than
220 dead in less than a month
the highly infectious delta strain
malnourishment and underlying health
problems all adding to the risk
of
the pandemic has already left more than
1200 children here dead
pediatricians say vaccinating over
twelves should be a priority
and while indonesia's infection rates
have finally started to drop
for the mourners
it's already too late
siobhan robbins sky news